[Music]
hey guys welcome back to off the record
we talk about whatever
we love hey what's up y'all
hey thank you for showing me your
beautiful music that went
um viral because like i want to be a
musician too
you are a musician joe you are a
musician dude
you even have a rap album i think it's
just a special team that's exactly what
he was doing no
but like we got to bring him down you're
not very good
i know but like i'm not like
professional you have to sing like a
disney princess like it's cool
that's the thing try a whole new way
oh nice okay good thank you it's pretty
good i wish i had a piano
i got shot oh yeah
just don't who's blowing into it i'll do
it oh
jesus okay that's it
nice oh no that was great do you have
perfect pitch
i don't know how to read notes if you
know what middle c is
by heart just like without playing it
that's when you would know well now you
just played it so let me try
middle c yeah you heard him he just
heard it
do other ones he's not gonna get it
play different team play different notes
okay hold up
i'm already not gonna get it because 23
of me says
i'm uh off key by 50 okay well let's see
if they're wrong that's super accurate
let's see if they're wrong it does
c c that's they already [ __ ] up play
it
i don't think it is c that sounds more
like c
hmm oh you're a little just a little bit
he's pitchy he's pitching what kind of
pitch he did
how about laurcie
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] dude oh man
well bart hit me up to do a jam sesh in
beginning quarantine but he never sent a
video of herself oh yeah
yo let's have a live one remember we
used to have those
i [ __ ] miss music man i miss it i
love that y'all are like secret
musicians you know what i mean
secret shitty ones dude i set up the
drum set in my
in my house because i'm like you know
what i need to at least just begging me
for years to set up
three years and i'm like i need to
unleash this creativity yeah so i get on
there
and i play i'm like god damn i suck i
put this thing down i go somewhere else
i've played it again no way is it still
there though
yeah good and every time i get on i'm
like ah [ __ ] off beat as a
[ __ ]
you are playing a lot in the office when
you had it set up over there
the other office each time was i would
play and i'm like i suck and i just put
it down
and i couldn't tell because it looked
like you're really into it it's because
i have headphones so i'm hearing what's
really going on
in your mind yeah it doesn't sound good
i bought a 5 000 piano
it was a baldwin the old school one
because you know like before
it was american made and it has that
like sound it's all like warm and it's
that character
of like kind of like sure
so um but then afterwards korea started
making it and it sounds a little bit
too like clean and weird you know what i
mean like yeah the asian piano is a
little too clean i like it a little bit
more but so i got one right and i was
like all alright
finally i'm gonna learn how to read
notes i'm gonna play this and then i can
learn
other songs i'm gonna do this [ __ ] and
guess what
corona happened no it got dusty on my
piano
i played it a couple times and then
they'll be like can you play a song for
me i'll i'll be like
jingle bell jingle bell okay i'm done
and i close it so it's an upright piano
five thousand bucks that's not bad
it isn't it's used though of course
because like
i mean new pianos are like 35 grand i
know
do you have a steinway no i've been
yamaha i'm endorsed so
shout out to yama thank you yamaha
[ __ ] athlete
yeah yamaha athlete so we go off-roading
you know
jet skis that you're sponsored that's
sick i got it
i got still you you have to pay um i got
my
upright piano half off cool but it's
brand new
but they hooked me up with some
keyboards yeah well the upright piano
that i got
i still had to pay like 13 grand that's
half off
it's cool though because it's a silent
piano so you hook up headphones and it's
playing midi that's something
yeah so then you could the digital kind
too
it was a thousand bucks it's not like
crazy i don't like but it's also
acoustic
the new pianos sound too clean to me i
like my world dirty
this piano sounds interesting so it's an
actual like piano with strings in it so
piano with strings hardware strings
silences it when you want to you press
the pedal on the bottom
it silences the action but it still
controls as
midi so that's it puts a blanket on the
back essentially like
yeah like it comes out and it's like
that
it's pads that go on it so you're
playing the action's still there
but you can hook it up to a computer and
have it be
mini keyboard so you can edit i like new
pianos now i only know what it looks
like in the back
because uh when i was a kid in our
living room we had
the piano in the corner of the room no
then like
for some reason i like throwing stuff
back there so my mom can't find it
and there's all my mom's looking for it
here's my chance to like
bring it out and then go it was right
there you didn't see it
wow so when i could jump back there the
the back part of the piano like half of
it's exposed and i would just see
strings
and that's gonna take a screwdriver and
go real real
[Laughter]
bro you know how you know how i found
now so my dad's uh
boy stories are so bad he's a piano
teacher and a musician right so we had a
couple pianos in the garage and he was
working on one
so it was exposed it was upright and i
was like what the [ __ ] that [ __ ] looks
like a harp right
it looks crazy yeah so i'm gonna like
clean with it like a harp and he had to
go inside and do
something and i was like oh [ __ ] what is
going to happen when i get these pliers
because just a week ago i learned how to
use pliers and cut like metal and i was
like
no ping ping ping
all of them all of them i got my ass
beat so
[ __ ] hard dude i got [ __ ] how old
were you
i don't know i was a kid but i was old
enough to remember was it someone else's
piano he was tuning or something
it was hours oh how much does it cost to
get it rewired i don't know
a lot of money it's gotta be a couple
grand it's gotta be i remember every
time i got my ass beat he just kept
complaining about how much money i cost
him
that bet that's like well like anything
each one sounds different
yeah technically piano is a string
instrument because of all the strings
yeah
but it's in the rhythm section but wow
i know dude cause it's percussive it's a
bunch of hammers it's like a percussion
instrument but it's technically a string
instrument because that's
right how do you know that do you play
what do you play
typical asian grew up learning how to
play piano yeah
classical yeah yeah yeah and then i had
to like
beg to be able to play the guitar which
i thought was cooler at the time
yeah yeah that's like being a rock star
yep yeah yeah and then
when i finally joined a band i just
played the bass so it didn't feel so
cool anymore
the beast is tight too you slept in a
basement i never learned how to slap the
bass
i could never do it like a stream
basically no no like you look like a
bass player
do i what what what what does the bass
player look like yeah what does baseball
look like just like
quiet usually quiet tall and lanky
yeah kind of that i had those
characteristics did you play some funky
ass [ __ ]
you didn't know how to slap the
basically funky [ __ ] and i couldn't slap
would you say i was like because she was
like what what instrument does it look
like yeah
like a cello or violin or something
she's like a tambourine girl
flute maybe flute oh you did
okay i could see that i see a bagpipe i
did i was in bed
first second character oh i didn't make
it that far
it was a junior high man gotcha ages
like
so like i played a lot of instruments
growing up and then um i got serious in
junior high
and then i discovered what being cool
was so i was like
instruments are cool though they're
super [ __ ] cool but at that point
it's like you don't want to be in bed it
ain't cool
it's cool i got into weed yeah it's cool
when you're good
and then you're able to woo the girls
but when you're still like
like you're like oh that's not cool and
you gotta you gotta be that geek at
school
around the case it's like oh it is
harder
i would say my case was small like that
yeah we still you saw this geek with
this [ __ ] case
but then you put stickers on it and
you're cool and then you open it and
you're like
and you open it and you gotta like
[ __ ] clean the instrument with the
[ __ ] [ __ ]
and then the mouthpiece you gotta suck
on it a little bit you know you played
clarinet
i did play claire i knew it yeah i
played clarinet for a little bit this
doesn't look cool
but i ended up playing piano for um for
like the choir
it was there was not enough guys to be
inquired so it was a women's choir but i
was the only guy in there
because i was playing piano what a stud
did they make you wear a wig
they only wanted women yeah they're like
it's a woman's quiet qualified
you have to qualify now i can only sing
up here
but i did play piano in jazz band and in
orchestra so
it was like it was cool for me and it's
i think that
like i hated that stereotype that only
like girls played piano
what that's a stereotype yeah it's like
that's it's like a
it's like a girly instrument i didn't
know that yeah i hated thinking about
how people who taught you this did la la
land change your mind
oh i mean or little richard myself
changed my mind
wait who taught you who taught you this
fib
the the girl thing i would just hear it
from probably my white friends probably
oh i didn't think like the flute was a
girl instrument other
instruments because it looks like
[ __ ] in no no
it's pretty like what do you think
that was really pretty that's why nobody
touches his instruments
yeah yeah yeah i'm glad you just like
have played that nah everybody that's
the only instrument i've ever played
the recorder like like a class because i
do get signed up on recorded class
yeah in sixth grade that's tight yeah
that's true that's like the instrument
everybody did yeah that was the easiest
[ __ ] there's no notes it's just circles
just circles yeah there's like dots that
you follow
super easy but piano then in theory
would be easier well i've never played
this dude growing up i would
beg my mom like like cry and beg like
please i want to take piano lessons so
bad and we just couldn't afford it she
took it from my parents they would have
made you hate piano i think my ears
still ringing how did you learn how to
play piano
uh my dad as well my dad hey i bet you
your dad made it fun
he did and but it got to a point where
he i think he was probably tired of
you know having rehearse rehearse all
the time so he ended up getting me um
a teacher how did they clean it
oh you know if you want to keep the
white keys
on your piano clean i'm just kidding no
you can't be cleaning
piano with no oxygen it's for
clothes but it works really well for
clothes especially if you got a kid
like we do and he's always getting grass
stains chocolate stains candy stains ice
cream stains all kind of stains
and before i would see a stain like a
coffee stain on a white shirt and i'm
like oh no
it's ruined i pretty much have to throw
it away cause it's gonna end up being
like a residual yellow spot
now with the oxiclean max force i just
spray it on let's
sit overnight and it's completely brand
new so i really like it if you guys have
whites and you want to keep it clean
make sure you go check that out so you
got to try oxyclean max force for
yourself to work your magic with
oxiclean
go to oxyclean.com maxforce1 to get a
coupon for
one dollar off
so your pops was a musician too yeah he
was he was really great musician
um conductor and choir leader and
did he teach you the fun way or did he
go here's some
[ __ ] classical [ __ ] and you know
what i think
he loved pop music and choral music so
much like
uh like secular music he played in the
church and stuff isn't that illegal
though um
to play secular music in church no he
loved it outside of the church right so
secular secular just means non-christian
secular just means
not in religious music because he played
for uh different churches like six
different churches every sunday i
remember us going to so many different
types of hood hopper
but on the friday and saturday i was a
church hopper on fridays and saturdays
he would play with his pop band
oh ty you know which was really cool and
that's what inspired me to
to go outside of the box and not play
classical anymore
and uh you know when he passed away i
was 10 years old
and we still had his keyboards and stuff
and i was like i don't want to play
classical music
kind of reminds me of that stuff but i
was always playing
pop music on his keyboard that's ty
dancing queen and stuff
and things like that from his books that
he left i was so
so random apple music i thought that's
do you want to play the it queen with me
dancing queen
it was cool like the synth part you know
i loved learning like the
the cool parts so i mean i ended up
playing
at all his churches essentially take
over
um and my mom became the choir director
and i became the pianist
you know so we split his job into two
and then i
kind of i mean that's why i do i still
continue to play
that's tight music yeah that's like my
story but better
wait so your dad was a musician oh yeah
it's like i saw a rainbow just like go
over his head when he said that
no like it was a similar story classical
music he came to the states
to pursue like um like opera and [ __ ] so
he
he was a classical musician he um
studied at uh or like he
apprenticed from for this guy at usc he
he was on japanese tv and
all this [ __ ] he ran mad choirs for like
multiple churches and stuff
but man he made music really not
fun like i get my ass beat every time i
did the keys wrong like he
ran it like hitler like really strict
hell yeah man it felt like
i was a part of a russian ballet and
[ __ ] you know
like belly's tough why are you binding
my feet this is piano dad
for the pedals i know right gotta wear
wooden toe shoes with a pedal he's
[ __ ] sucked
yeah and then um i just hated like i
think i
i learned how to just remember songs
really fast
so uh i get like in trouble if i don't
play the things right right so that i
pretend that i'm
like playing the keys so i don't get my
ass beat like it felt like north korea
were like
i want to eat dinner today
is he still around yeah [ __ ] that guy we
like talk
on the phone well there was a stint like
many many years that oh yeah he left
when i was like 13.
that's where that guy yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah you can't leave vital
no no but it's funny though i know but
it's funny when i leave it out that way
okay fine he's like then you should have
started with you wish he was dead
no but that's where i was gonna get to
that's where the punch is because his
his dad passed but i'm just like i wish
that your dad stayed alive because he
deserved it and mine did it
that's what i'm saying yeah you ruined
the punch for me
anyways you ruined it i got it i
appreciate that big heart he was he felt
bad for you
huh i felt bad for him no it's okay i
appreciate it it's just funny right how
like
we can both uh be raised like in a a
music environment but depending on the
person
and how they communicate the art or
teach the you might hate it or
yeah it changes the game man i think a
lot of asian kids that are forced to do
music they don't really get to
appreciate the love for it because it's
so
um there's no soul to it dude and
they're being forced to yeah like
do it because you i want you to just be
[ __ ] dope
so i can be like hey look at my kid they
could play beethoven
at two years old you know that's true to
show off and stuff yeah like the [ __ ] is
wrong with you
what about self-expression and having
another way of
you know like expressing yourself and
being artistic and learning [ __ ] like
that
my dad wasn't like that he hated those
type of parents he would actually be
like
i don't want to teach your kids anymore
damn yeah i remember going to recitals
and like the kid will be playing and my
mom like you see how straight that guy's
sitting
i'm like well yeah but the song sucks
yeah i'm like who gives a [ __ ] the way
look at his tuxedo i'm like i don't give
a [ __ ] about that but that's also why i
hated
and and still not a huge fan of
classical music because it kind of keeps
you in a box you have to play it exactly
how the composer
did it you know i love playing church
music pop music it's just chords
so you just play freestyling yeah you're
freestyling you know what i mean you
interpret the way you want to so
honestly i don't even know how they knew
how all those symphonies were
yeah if they didn't record it so how the
[ __ ] do you know
that's how it's been maintained i feel
you the dynamics on the paper they're
really strict about that stuff that's
why
that's why that culture is that strict
because you have to follow what's on the
book
to follow exactly even the way your
fingers go on it because they put
like the numbers on the thing and the
second finger has to play that note
you know it's very specific and it's uh
that's it keeps you in a box i'd say
yeah i have uh the piano that i
mentioned that i have it's a smart piano
so you could like plug in and on a pad
yeah and then it teaches you because
there's like lights and stuff so is it
yamaha
it's called the it's called the one
piano yeah oh
like yeah anyway so i was trying to
learn this one song and then i
i nailed the right hand i was like [ __ ]
yeah
yeah good and then i nailed the left
[ __ ] yeah i got this [ __ ]
and i combined it i couldn't play a
single note
i was like what the [ __ ] that's hard
because once that one's rhythm right and
the other one's like melody
yeah i couldn't i couldn't make them
both happen but also i think i did
too much because like i said i've never
really played anything
and that was the first day that i just
sat down and the piano was in the
beginning of quarantine i'm like i'm
gonna [ __ ] learn piano by the end of
quarantine
and i did like i did like three hours oh
[ __ ]
and and then i haven't touched it since
i think it's hard myself
that's kind of how i felt when i tried
to learn uh tried to learn the drums
because i was like okay
i i've played instruments where you have
the one hand and then two hands
but then drums you're putting in both
feet where i'm just like there's too
many [ __ ] limbs moving at once i
can't do
this there's eighth notes here and
there's quarter notes here
yeah yeah you gotta do one of these
things man are you just opening and
closing the hi-hat
i don't know you're saying how it was
like really interesting
like the perspective of like the parents
approach and how the kids turned out
whether
they love it or hate the music for me i
had a parent like my mom was super
supportive of anything i wanted to do in
the arts
so she allowed me to do whatever i
wanted and i did
but because she wasn't really strict
about it she was like as soon as i was
like
i've learned enough i'm bored i want to
do the next thing she was like okay
but now looking back i'm like damn it i
wish she was just a little bit strict a
little bit more discipline huh yes but i
would try it two more times because i
know
i know a little bit of a lot of things
and i'm like [ __ ] i never got to like
finish it because like as a kid i was
really fickle and like
bored you know it's important i think
for us to
finish something when you're young hell
yeah
when do you finish piano classes get to
the
get to a point where you can just pull
up any note like tabs like you know
music theory you know you can make your
own music
yeah where you just read the notes and
you go you can start playing it sight
read or whatever i think
that is being able to play
yeah you could take lessons for years
and not be able to do that though yeah
so to me i don't even think they're a
piano player like if for me a musician
that
for that instrument means not only can
you read the music you should be able to
hear and play immediately and also
create your own
yeah if it's like we're going to jam out
in the kia or then you're a guitar
player but if you have to go
like dependent yeah if you can't just
play your own [ __ ] or you can't read
music or you can't play according to ear
i don't even think you're a guitar
player
you're not a technically an artist yet
you know you're just a follower
well i'm learning my mom played for many
many years but she
can't go beyond tabs oh she's not
comfortable in freestyling she's not
comfortable
and i think that's normal for a lot of
musicians some people are just they do
yeah they just do one thing i mean
there's a lot of musicians who also
they swear by not being able to read
music and they do it by ear which is
obviously very cool and a great talent
to have but i
will always like advocate learning what
you're playing
and so you're able to communicate with
other musicians in case
that's all you know that's my limitation
yeah because not because i want to be
cool it's just that i never
learned that way yeah yeah no i'm uh i
met
this bass player he's like one of the
most recorded bass players in
in all of music pinot paladino like
legend he played on tori kelly's um
album and i was like there's a pain in
the ass to work with he's gonna read
music
well he said that i was just like dude
you're a freaking legend man he's like
well one time i went in for a movie uh
because a
very big composer i don't want to just
get it wrong but
asked him to play and he said hey man
unfortunately i can't read this and he
got replaced
you know what i mean yeah i mean because
he's an amazing bass player just like on
his own
just improviser does this stuff by feel
yeah which is cool but there
there are certain jobs that maybe uh
you'll get locked out of but that's not
to say that he's not any
more of a legend than he is or any less
than it you know what i mean but
i feel like there is a strong point of
being able to read music
like you said being able to create your
own and be able to just jam with it
because it's the common language too
that like
i don't even know what half these terms
anymore but you know when there's like a
coda or whatever like
if you're if you're in a big band and
everyone has to play all right from this
part like everyone knows what from the
top means that's what you're talking
right but if you're from this bar
from here and if you're not everyone can
oh
were you trying to say teacher then like
everyone's not on the same page
and you have to orchestrate like 100 200
pieces so i think that part's pretty
important
yeah yeah i mean yeah there's a
difference between like a session player
someone or someone in an orchestra
and and someone who's just like their
own artist and stuff and i think
all of them can thrive on their own and
be successful of course
but it is cool and i do love encouraging
like
young players and stuff to keep their
classical chops but also
break out of that so you can make your
own music i want to learn classical
chops
i thought you said that you that was
what you started with
i forgot all of it yeah yeah that's the
problem i think
it gets like so hammered into you and
and rehearsing and stuff and you you're
crying and [ __ ] and like you don't want
to
play anymore your brain shits it out i
just freestyle everything now
yeah and you memorize it for the recital
yep but after that
you take it out here it's literally like
midterms and finals like forcing you to
have pretty
yeah yeah like who remembers that stuff
right now
[Music]
you